hello everyone as you may or may not
know
I'm in the middle of a rather extensive
International tour I have a couple of
lectures
that still have tickets available and so
maybe you'd like to attend
I understand that there are some people
for whom my mere presence in the same
Global hemisphere provokes fits of peak
and resentment
chocolatito
don't let that discourage you
I want to let those of you who are
interested know that tickets to two
events are still available
at the ice Hall in Helsinki Finland
on Sunday October 9th
the other rather newly announced
at the Honda Center in Anaheim
California on Thursday
November 3rd everyone is of course
welcome to attend regardless of their
political beliefs
[Applause]
oh Jesus
thank you hope to see you there